all right everyone thanks for coming to
this
talk um this is pipeline oriented
programming um and actually I've decided
that's actually a too too boring there's
so much more other interesting trendy
techy stuff so actually going to do a
completely different talk on Quantum
powered chat gbt in the
cloud that's much more cool it's much
more trendy so no actually if anyone if
you know me you know I'm never going to
let you down I'm never going to talk
about trendy stuff I'm going to talk
about boring stuff like software design
and functional programming and stuff
like that so yes I am going to be
talking about pipeline oriented
programming so I'm Scott vloan that's me
on Twitter and also on Foster
Don um the slides and the code if you
want to play with the code it's um I
have a git repo and that's linked at my
website fhop forun and profit pipeline
I'm going to do code examples in C and F
and um I'll start off in C and as I get
more complicated I'm going to move to F
and you'll see why and this is this is
not really an FSH lesson you don't need
to know anything about F and actually if
you're kind of curious about F shop this
is a good a good way to see some code
you know I'm actually going to some real
code you can see what it looks like in
action so part
one what is pipeline oriented
programming well let me compare it with
object oriented
programming um to show you the
difference so object oriented
programming you have this kind of
component and you send a request and you
get a response so it's a message-based
model and inside this component you know
an object will talk to another object
which will talk to another object and
there's lots of back and forth chatter
between these objects and sometimes the
chatter goes both directions like
something like the visitor pattern where
you're going back and forth so the thing
about this is in O arrows go in all
directions this is the main thing that
that I want to take away about oo really
is going get now people say don't try
and do that but it's it's very easy to
do that in oo so in Pine or programming
it's a pipeline right all the arrows go
in the same direction you have and it's
an input output model so rather than
thinking of request response there's a
pipeline something comes in and it goes
through the pipeline and it comes out
get other side and as it goes through
the pipeline gets transformed in various
ways like each of these little
individual subcomponents will transform
the data right so if you know Unix style
pipes it's exactly the same right you
have a command line and you pipe the
data through with First Command second
command so on so it's just like Unix
style thing except you can actually
apply to all sorts of stuff and not just
like command line stuff so for example
you can apply it to a web
backend so if you think about it a web
back end is an input and output that
something comes in which is the request
and something comes out which is the
response and you can actually design a
web app us using these pipelines without
any kind of O sty at all um there is
obviously branching because you make
decisions obviously but the the arrows
all go in the same direction and I'm
actually going to show you a demo later
on of exactly how to do this and this is
a very different way of thinking about
design than you would be if you're doing
kind of an O style design so hopefully
that'll be interesting to you so what
are the benefits of pipelines I'm going
to talk about benefits and then I'm
going to do some demos to actually kind
of
um you know push them home so first
benefit I think is composability so
composability means like Lego where you
build bigger things and smaller things I
think pipelines actually encourage you
to follow good design principles even
more than with oo I think pipelines are
easy to maintain and I think pipelines
make testing easier and I think
pipelines fit really well with modern
architectures like onion architecture
hexagonal architecture clean
architecture etc etc right they're
different from the classic enter
architectures so let's look at each one
of these in turn let's look at
composability
first so composability I always like to
use Lego as an analogy Lego is a
fantastically composable toy right so
here's some Lego and the thing about
Lego is you can take any two pieces of
Lego and connect them together to make
another piece of Lego right and that's
what's so great about it every single
piece has the little bumps on it and you
connect them together and the piece that
you make still has little bumps on it so
you don't need a special adapter you
know to add pieces I could take two of
these little toy things and stick them
together to make a a double decker you
know so you can keep adding and adding
and um making bigger things from a bunch
of smaller things so that's why Lego is
such a great thing and that's why
pipelines are such a great thing too
because pipelines encourage you to do
the same kind of thing they encourage
you to build pieces that can be
connected in all sorts of different ways
they're not like one use only you can
actually design your if you're thinking
in a pipeline oriented way you like how
can I build these pieces so they can be
connected in different ways like they go
and again with with pipeline stuff you
design them so they don't need adapters
they can literally normally just be
plugged together straight away and
you'll see well how you know what does
that actually look like and again hold
on a second I will show you in a minute
so you get nice composable components if
you do this kind of
style and of course you can glue the
small components together to make a
bigger component and then encapsulate
that by and you then now hiding what's
inside so you still got your
encapsulation you now have a you know an
input and an output but you don't
actually know what's going on inside so
all the all the things of encapsulation
and stuff you still get the same
benefits of
that right number two good design
principles so if you're used to O design
patterns and oo principles like solid
and so on these work perfectly with
pipeline oriented style design you don't
have to throw them away so let me give
you some examples let's look at single
responsibility for starters so the whole
point of single responsibility is you do
one thing and you do it really well
right you don't have a 100 different
methods on your interface or your object
right well this has one input and one
output you can't get much more single
responsibility in that so by definition
if you're writing components like this
you automatically have single
responsibility you can't you don't have
to check it with code of views you
literally can't help it right you're
forced to do this way what about open
closed so open close you can add new
functionality but you don't mess with
existing code your existing code Works
don't touch it right so you can add to
that but you don't want to you want to
be messing with existing code well if
you do a pipeline oriented approach it's
very easy just add new things into the
pipeline and the rest of the pipeline
you haven't touched right so you can add
it before you can add it after you can
add it in the middle all right so you've
extended the behavior but you haven't
touched the rest of the codes so the
open close principle works really well
with pipeline in fact again I think it
it's like it just falls out naturally
you don't even have to try it just kind
of comes with the territory and I'm
going to show you some examples of this
in a minute including one that you're
all very familiar with which is link so
I'm going to start with a link example
and it'll show you it'll demonstrate
this
perfectly um strategy pattern right you
want you have some sort of piece of code
and you want to parameterize how it
works by passing in some sort of
strategy well you just pass in a
component right this is my whole
pipeline I want the Behavior to change
based on something else well I just pass
in a component if I pass in a different
component it's going to behave
differently but I'm not messing with the
rest the code so that's very easy and
decorator pattern again I want to change
I have a component I want to change the
behavior let's say I want to log the
input and log the output um I can just
add new pieces at either end and then
encapsulate that and now I have a new
pipeline which has the same inputs and
outputs as the original pipeline so it's
completely substitutable everywhere I
could use used the original pipeline I
can now use this decorated
pipeline right so that's the decorator
pattern so all these things are kind of
so obvious you don't really need you
know to talk about them just kind of
follow from the whole pipeline oriented
way of doing
things right what about easy to maintain
so this is a bit of a claim because I
don't actually have any evidence but to
be honest there's hardly any kind of
rigorous evidence for anything in
programming which is sad but um I'm
going to claim that the bottom one the
pipeline one is easier to maintain than
the top one the objectoriented
one um and I think the reason is because
with the o1 you can really get into a
mess you know I mean you can have these
guidelines like don't do that don't get
into a mess don't have 100 methods don't
have it but it's really easy to do it
you know especially if you're trying to
some get something out of the door at
you know 3:00 in the morning on a Friday
whatever so you know with the pipeline
thing it's really hard to it's it's
you're less likely to get into the mess
in the first place because it just
doesn't really support that way of
thinking and here is an example of a a
real world dependency graph for a c
project you can't see it and this is
actually just a quart of it each of
these things is a little class and the
lines are the dependencies between the
class and you can't really see them but
what I can tell you is that the arrows
in this go in all
directions and um you trying to
understand how this works this kind of
be quite confusing way and in particular
one thing which is really bad is you
have these circular dependencies where a
class depends on another class which
depends on the third class which depends
on the first class and you have some
sort of cycle those are deadly they
really shouldn't exist and again you can
have guidelines to say don't do that but
if you do that then you've broken your
lay you can't refactor these things you
can't pull these things out so Cycles
are really really deadly and if you're
using C I would recommend using
something like end depend or something
which will help you detect these things
but definitely don't have them now
here's the F version and this is an F
version of the same um
logic so it's a lot fewer these are not
classes these are modules in f um but
what you can't see really is that all
the arrows are going in left to
right so if I'm if I'm trying to
understand this code obviously it's
quite complex but um again there's no
Cycles in this code it's all one way so
that's
nice right so two more benefits I talked
about which was testing and architecture
I will leave that to the end because I
don't want to bore you with too much
talking um but at the end of the talk
I'll I'll go back to testing an
architecture you see hopefully you'll
see that it works really well for this
right so let's actually look at some
pipeline oriented code in practice
enough enough enough talk here so this
is a for Loop in
C and um it's doesn't really it's a very
stupid example but you know trying to
figure out what it does it's not 100%
easy because there's various things
there's a branch and there's various
things going on there's a mutation and
so on
now let's look at the same code in
link right now I claim that this is
easier to understand than the for Loop
right I mean I can just look at this and
I can see what's going on now it's not
necessarily as performance the for Loop
might be more performant but in terms of
just understanding what the code's doing
I think this is easier because I can see
that you're you're converting you're
adding two to everything and then you're
doing a filter and then you're adding
the count you're returning the count I
think this is much easier than the full
loop thing so link is a great example of
of pipeline oriented programming so if
you ever done link you you already know
how to do
this now let's look at the composability
so in
link all the different methods do one
thing they do they single responsibility
they do one thing and they do one thing
well and they're designed to fit
together in different
ways right it's a composable link is a
kind of Lego like system you can you can
mix and match all the different
components right so that's nice
um and so what I'm trying to say is link
is a great example of how you should be
writing your code if you can write codes
in a way where you can mix and match
your components and then connect them
into a pipeline that'll be a it's it's a
really nice
design there's the single
responsibilties each one of these things
does one thing and because of that it's
easy to understand what it does once you
understand what this particular method
does you know it doesn't do 20 different
things it does one thing and it does it
well and it's if you're writing this
kind of stuff it's easy to test because
I just have to test the thing in
isolation and then when I put all these
different pieces together each
individual piece has been tested and I
can pretty I can be pretty confident
that the whole thing's going to work
right I don't have to worry that the
whole thing's not going to work even
though the individual pieces work like
if if the pieces work you know I still
want to do some integration testing sure
but I don't I'm not going to worry that
it's broken I'm going to be pretty
confident that it's going to work and
then of course you can add and remove
things from the pipeline I can add
another wear Clause I can add another
select clause I can do a sort I can do
you know all the different things you
can do with link right there's there's
like I know 50 different things you can
do so I can I can easily add things to
the pipeline and I'm pretty confident I
haven't broken anything now if I was
going back to the for Loop and I wanted
to add another
filter I would I be confident I haven't
broken anything I don't know you know
I'd have to I'd have to be really
careful when I change that foret because
I might break something but here I'm
very confident if I add a new thing I
haven't broken anything so here's the F
code the same kind of thing so F you can
use Link in F but link F has its own
built-in collection stuff like this so
select is called map in F and where is
called filter and in count it's called
length and um this is exactly the same
kind of code in F now the thing about f
it uses this pipe
operator and in Unix it's a vertical bar
and in F it's a vertical bar with an
angle
bracket so uh it's not the vertical bar
is used for something else right right
so it's vertical part angle bracket and
you will see this all the time in F so
this means take the list set the the
list collection feed it into the map
function and you know add two to then
take the output of that feed it into the
filter function take the output of that
and feed it into the length function so
it's very similar to link these are not
extension methods these are
Standalone um Standalone functions so
it's slightly
different right now one thing where
pipelines are really useful is when
you're doing a mut ility right so more
more people using immutability which I
think is great I think everything should
actually be immutable
um if you you are doing immutability
you're probably going to need some sort
of pipeline thing and I'll give you an
example let's say I have a a record
structure here and you know this is
immutable so I want to modify the name
and then I want to modify the email I
want to modify the age and so on each
time I do that I'm creating a new you
know a new version of the
person and it's you know it's quite
common to do this kind of thing and this
is really ugly right it's very
repetitive it's kind of ugly um let's
not do it let's not do it this is this
is kind of I would say ugly code so
what's the alternative well you can just
dot them you know do Cascade of dots
right so kind of fluent fluent interface
would be another way of talking about it
so um fluent interface is another way of
doing pipeline same you know same kind
of thing this is much nicer you don't
have to have all these variables and
stuff so pipeline oriented stuff makes
immutability it's very very common where
you have a a chain of functions or
methods and you're you're modifying
something as you go through and
obviously this is oh
de I just got a blue screen sorry about
that I'm just going to restart my
computer that is kind of annoying sorry
sorry
folks of course that's Murphy's law that
would do a blue screen right in the
middle of a presentation
wonder what
something okay well after just uh talk
among yourselves anyway just so what was
I going to say oh yeah mutable data so
how many people I'm just curious how
many people are using mutable stuff in
their code now a lot of people yeah so
presumably you've run into this problem
where you have to kind of chain um
actually another good example is link
where the the sequences are kind of
immutable you know you're making new
sequences as you go through the the
pipeline
here just
rebooted let see if I
can
where am I right here we
go
okay so uh yes this is ugly and this is
much
nicer and um another thing you might be
thinking about is something like link is
an extension method right what's the
difference between extension methods and
piping like in F you use piping and in
link use extension methods so I'm going
to demonstrate that too um let's say I
have two functions right three functions
actually and I want to add one and then
I want to square it and then I want to
double it right so the traditional way
would be to use some sort of nested Co
like this um I find that kind of
sometimes you get really deeply nested
and it's kind of ugly right so if I want
to make this look nicer I'll use a
pipeline right I'm going to use a
pipeline so five and then add one and
then square and then double that's much
easier to see what's going on without
all this nesting stuff problem is of
course this doesn't work because these
things are not extension methods right
so I can't do that however there is a
trick that I can make these work and the
trick is I can make a generic helper
that will turn anything into an
extension method and that is going to be
called pipe right so this is the pipe in
C um it's got a lot of generic par it's
got two generic parameters um so it's a
bit conf it's kind of hard to look at
sometimes but basically there's an input
here of and that's the input and then
the other thing you pass in is a
function which has an input and output
so it's a one parameter function and all
you do is just call the function with
the input that's
it so that's what pipe is is pretty easy
to to go with each step for all the
generic stuff now if I use this pipe
extension method I can actually go back
and rewrite this using
piping so um you know I think that's
nicer obviously this is a in real life
you would never do this for adding and
squaring numbers obviously it's way too
simple but you can get the idea that you
can actually if you had a more complex
thing you could actually turn it into a
pipeline quite
nicely now the problem is this only
works for functions with one input so
how do I do two input functions well I
just have a let's say adding two numbers
together or multiplying two numbers
together they won't fit into the
pipeline right so how do I do that well
I just have another overload of pipe and
I have an extra parameter now and when I
I call the function I pass in the
original input and I which is coming
down the pipeline and also the extra
parameter the second
parameter right so that's how you would
Implement a two parameter version you
can have a three parameter version a
four you can have overloads you know as
many overloads as you like for this so
if I do that overload as well then I can
use addition and multiplication in my
pipeline by just passing in the extra
parameter right so there's my extra
parameter and there's me passing in the
extra so the fun five is passed down the
pipeline as the first parameter and the
one is added as the second parameter
that's going to be five add one right um
and then it's going to be which is going
to be what six and then the second one
is going to be six and multiply by
two so why again in real life you
wouldn't do this for simple
multiplication but why would you even
bother to go to all this trouble of
having a special
pipeline well again because we can do
all this stuff like adding things into
the pipeline removing things in the
pipeline
composing different functions together
in different ways right so all the
benefits I talk about with the link so
this is not link this is adding and
multiplying numbers together but now I
have a composable version of that if you
wanted to have a kind of building blocks
for ma from doing mathematics I could do
it this way same kind of thing one
really nice thing about this also is the
diffs look great so if you're doing a
code of view and you're seeing what code
changed when you're doing pipeline
oriented stuff like like this the diffs
are really clean it's really I'm just
you added something in the middle of it
you know or remov something but you
always see these really really nice
diffs which is not going to be true if
I'd gone back to my original like for
Loop and I've modified things it would
get really it's not obvious really
what's going on
so just in terms of communicating what's
going on pipelines are great so here's
the F code for adding and multiplying
and squaring and so on again I start
with five I feed it into add one I feed
it into multiply two and then so and so
forth so um f we'll see uses pipelines
everywhere so these are not extension
methods notice I didn't have to write a
special pipe helper in F you get it for
free because in f um functions are sort
of pipeline compatible out of the box
most almost all functions are pipeline
compatible so you know sometimes in CSH
this is and I'm going to start using F
more and more because in C it can get a
little bit kind of frustrated ating like
using pipe I mean you can see it's it's
not really a natural fit for c i me it
works sometimes but in F you know it's
never going to make you cry about you
know not having the right adapter and so
on so
um thing about extension methods
compared to pipelines is you can't use
them as
parameters so let's say I have a
strategy like this I have a list and
some sort of strategy function and I'm
doing that same kind of Link thing where
selecting something and then I'm doing a
wear clause and I'm doing my count and
in the middle I want to inject my
parameterized function maybe I'm going
to do a different filter or maybe I'm
going to do another select or something
I'm going to decide oh the blind it's
gone again sorry people I've got another
blue
screen why is it doing
that um I'll try and keep talking while
I reboot again of
course don't know maybe it just doesn't
like this
room hopefully there's not too much
downtime between the reboots it's like
sorry about this okay so um what was I
saying about the
um
uh injecting a parameter um it's hard to
do that because these you know the
functions that or the methods you inject
can't fitted straight into the pipeline
so what you can
do and if this does this again I'm going
to go crazy
here just I'm going to just
overheating
we
go so um I was saying that if you if
you you can't pass in a strategy
function and use it directly in the
pipeline but you can um that's not going
to work right you you can't just use a
function parameter but what you can do
is use the pipe helper function to do
this now in f here's the same FSH
code um with f as I say all functions
are kind of automatically pipeline
compatible so I don't need the special
helper to do this so you can see I'm
going to as I get more more into
pipeline coding I'm going to do using
more more F because it just gets kind of
unwieldy with cop so you can do it with
cop with extension methods and with um
um uh hel helper functions like pipe but
um f is like so as I get into more stuff
it's going to be more F right so I'm
going to do three demos to actually show
you some real code I'm going to do
pipeline oriented ran numerals pipeline
oriented fs buuz and a pipeline oriented
web API as I promised now all these are
pipeline oriented and one of the things
when you do pipelight oriented
programming you start designing the
solution differently than if you're
doing o so each of these is going to
have a very different design that you
might think of normally right so let's
start with Roman
numerals so this is something you've
probably all played with a bit right you
convert five into V and 12 into X11 and
so on and so forth right so there's lots
of different ways of doing this but I'm
going to do a pipeline oriented way and
I'm going to Bas this on the fact that I
think the Roman nums were originally
sort of a tally system where you kind of
make a whole bunch of marks on the wall
and then you cross them out when you get
to five and cross them out when you get
to 10 something like that so that's
going to be my design I'm going to start
with n copies of the letter I so like 42
copies of I and then every time I see
five I's I'm going to replace it with a
V and every time I see four v's two v's
I'm going to replace with an X and five
x is going to be an l and so on so forth
so literally going to do search and
replace that's my
algorithm so if in a pipeline model this
is what it looks like I start by making
42 copies of the I and then I just go
through each replacement step in turn in
the PIP
l so that's my that's my algi an
algorithm you probably wouldn't come up
with if you weren't thinking about
pipelines you probably have some sort of
for Loop right so here's the C code
right I make a string with n copies of
it and I do a replace and a replace and
a replace and a
replace right now you might notice that
I haven't done the extra cases like one
V there's some special cases like four
is actually One V not four ones well we
can just add some functionality to our
pip line really easy right I can extend
the behavior of the pipeline without
touching the original code so this is a
good example of how I can like oh we got
a new feature request we got to add
these new special cases oh just add them
at the bottom of the pipeline and again
your diff is going to look really nice
when you do this it's like what have you
changed I changed these four
lines here's the F version very very
similar except I'm using the pipeline
instead of using a fluent interface like
with a C I'm using the pipeline oriented
with the vertical
bar let's see if I can do a demo without
crashing my computer
here
whoops and now of course I have to
restart visal
Studio
super duper Speedy if
uh all right so here's the C- Cod as I
promised and um let's say I want to do
some logging right so in the C I can say
I can add new features into the middle
of the P I can do a log you know I can
do a log afterwards um I can do a log at
the bottom so in C I'm going to have to
do this by having an extension method
for strings to do the logging to to keep
it fluent um if I do the F code I don't
have to do that so let me show you the F
code now the nice thing about sharp you
can actually run it interactively so I
can highlight this
code and then actually get the answer so
there's the answer XXX so notice I
haven't done the special cases so here's
the version of the special cases I've
just added some extra code at the
bottom and now if I do it I get the nice
one with the 1X and the XL and so and
then here's my logging function so this
is a standalone logging function it's
not an extension method so I could
actually reuse this in many different
situations um because all functions are
kind of pipeline compatible I can just
stick it right into my
pipeline so there I'm logging in the
middle I'm logging at the thing and let
me just uh put this
here there we
go oops so that's what it says at the
start and then before the special Cas is
and the end so the logging is working
very nicely with the
pipeline
right now let's talk about
fizzbuzz so if you're not familiar with
fizzbuzz you're going to write a program
that prints numbers from one to n but if
it's divisible by three you print Fizz
instead of three and for five it's buzz
and for 15 it's fiz bar and so on
hopefully you will know how this works
right so here's a cop example this is a
pretty standard implementation right I'm
just looping from 1 to 30 and I'm just
comparing the different things so um
this is great if you're doing a job
interview definitely do it this way but
we're not going to do it this way
because this is too easy we're going to
make it more complicated right so no I'm
not going to make it more complicated
but I am going to make it more
composable so the problem with the
classic version is I want to add new
features to it um this just a monolithic
piece of code right so if I need to add
seven or something I want to add logging
I'm I'm I'm touching all the code I'm
not doing the open close thing if I
could make it a composable system I
could add logging I could add new
numbers without touching the existing
code so let's do that so the again
thinking pipeline how can I make a
pipeline oriented version of this well
I'm going to handle 15 I'm going to
handle three I'm going to handle five
and then I'm going to have the final
step where nothing's been handled right
so this is a pipeline of data flowing
through this pipeline now in order to do
this let's look at each one of these
steps so this number is going to come in
but there's actually two different
things that going to happen one is I'm
not going to handle that number like if
it like three then two and seven don't
count right I'm just to ignore them on
the hand you know if it's three coming
in then I might want to put Fizz as the
output so I need to handle both these
different um outputs possible outputs so
the one I'm going to do is create a new
data structure specifically for this
problem and the nice thing is you can do
it in one line of code now normally it's
not like a big deal it's like it's just
like one line of code just to solve this
problem I I think that's price worth
paying to get the composability so my
Vis data structure down here whoops is
going to have a string which is the
output and the number that's being
passed through now if the string empty
if the output string is empty that means
I haven't processed it and if the output
string is not empty it means I have
processed it so there are other ways of
doing this but I'm just going to keep it
very simple for
now so let's how see how we handle
something right so I pass in the data
structure and it's an extension method
because this is cop um the I'm dividing
by and the output that I only have fiz
or buz whatever so if it's already been
processed if it's not empty I'm going to
do nothing just return the data if it's
not divisible by the
thing it's not applicable I'm going to
return the thing otherwise I'm going to
create a new version of the data
structure and put the output in it right
so now it's been handled so that's my
Handler right now once I have a Handler
like this I can chain them together
right there's the
input and that is the data that's being
passed down the pipeline because it's an
extension method right that's the first
parameter is what is what's being passed
through the pipeline so I start off with
an empty data structure I handle the 15
case I handle the three case I handle
the five case and then the final step is
basically turn it into if it hasn't been
handled turn it into a string so this is
my fizzbuzz pipeline implementation now
this is probably something you would not
normally do if unless you were thinking
about
pipelines and then finally I can
actually do the 1 to 30 I can do that as
a pip well I'll start with a numerable
and then do a select I'm going to use
Link so there's a little mini pipeline
in there as well just for fun so that's
going to print it out right so let me do
a demo and I'm also going to show you
how I can do
parallelization with um with the
pipeline oriented program which is very
nice right where is my FB so here's the
classic version of fbus in fop same kind
of thing as the cop
version but let let me show you the the
f one so um here is my data
structure here's my Handler same it's
the same code as the c one right if I if
it's empty uh if it's not empty I've
already processed it and so on Here's
the final step which I didn't show you
which basically when turns it into
string if it's not been processed here's
a little logging thing which I'm going
to use later on right so here's my FSB
Bar's
pipeline right you can see that it's
piping each step through the hand handle
15 handle three handle five and so
on and so and again we want run it with
different
numbers there we go let's one and see
what happens there we go one two Fizz
four Buzz six is Fizz 15 is fizzbuzz and
so on so forth so it's
working right now um let me add some
logging and let me add a new Handler so
let's let's start with seven so you say
well you need to handle seven as well so
okay I've got new Fe
feature and I don't need to change any
of exting code I can just add it so I'm
very confident this is going to work if
I was doing that for Loop thing I mean f
is not that hard right but if it's a
more complicated I wouldn't I wouldn't
necessarily be confident it's going to
work but this I'm very very confident
it's going to work so let me do
this and where's the answers there we go
so I got zap in s zpp in 14 now what I
haven't
got if it's seven and three
I should have Fizz zap but I only got
Fizz so I'm not handling the
combinations right and you say well
that's a that's a that's a problem and
I'm going to fix that in a minute so
just hold on and then let me add some
logging I'm just going to put a log
right here log after
five and I I can say log after
15 okay so I've got some logging going
on I can stick it in the pipeline no
problem and
now if I look at the output you can see
it's leing after
15 um you know so after 15 30 like 30 is
outputting f buzz and so on so you can
actually see I've got logging going on
automatically right now let's talk about
this thing where um I want to do it in
parallel so um I can handle seven and
more complicated things without having
to do um uh special cases all the time
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
do a parallel version I'm going to pass
in a list of
handlers and um what I'm going to do is
just run each one independently in
parallel and then add the results
together so I just need this combine
operation here and there's my
Handler by the way notice I'm doing a
map followed by a reduce so if you know
about parallel program you know there's
a thing called map reduce and here I am
actually using it in real code so uh
let's do the parallel
version so here are I'm getting my Fizz
Buzz automatically even though I didn't
actually have the fizzbuzz case because
it's doing inal and if I add
seven again I can just add seven I don't
have to like change any other
codes and now if I do it in
parallel I'm getting uh oops I should it
should been zap
here
right there's that but I'm getting um if
I go to 21 I'm getting fiz zap right
three and seven and if I go to 35 I'm
getting Buzz zap so it's doing the I
don't have to have all these special
cases anymore because I'm doing in
parallel so this is something that you
would never think of doing really unless
you were thinking about these components
like I've got this little Handler and
this is a single responsibility thing
and once I've got this Handler for one I
can compose the the handlers for
different numbers together run them in
parallel you know combine the results
it's a whole different way of thinking
about how you might write a program but
it all started because I was thinking
about composability
right now let's finish up with a web API
so what does a a component um in a web
pipeline look like so I'm going to have
a pipeline for my website and it's going
to have components which are composed
together so how do you even do that
right so here's what a web component is
going to be it's going to have an input
and an output right now the input is
going to be called HTTP context which
contains the request and the cookies and
everything you need to know it's also
going to have the response because you
might have partially written to the
response right so the response is also
going to be part of the input for this
thing and you might add to the response
or replace the response and so on now
there's two different cases one case is
you've handled it you say oh this is I
this is something I can deal with and
I'm going to handle it just like fuz and
another case is like no this is a
situation I don't want to handle so I'm
not going to handle it so again there's
two different
outputs so if you think about if you're
used to middleware in in net um asp.net
it's kind of like that but I actually
think this is easier than the middleware
thing because it actually works
everywhere you'll see that this works I
can build the entire site this way so
again going back to the sort of Railway
track analogy which I like to use it's
like having a branch in your Railway
right so either something comes in and I
either handle it and return something
and by the way it's actually a in
practice it's an async that comes back
so because you can actually go out and
hit the database or something um and
then you know if it doesn't handle it it
just returns to nor so I got this
branching
code so let's look at a very simple web
component this is called get so all it
does is look at the request and see if
it's a get verb and if it is I've
handled it and if I if it doesn't match
the verb I don't handle it that's that's
all it does one thing single
responsibility all right let's look at
another one this one is called roots or
routes and it looks at the input and it
sees what the root of Route is and if it
matches I'm saying yeah I handled it and
if it doesn't match I didn't handle it
right again single
responsibility um here's another one set
the status code so all it does is set
the St code to something right now this
one always going to work because it's
just going to replace the response
so I have these three different
components and I want to glue them
together into a pipeline how do I do
that right so I have a get followed by a
root followed by a set status code well
I'm actually not going to tell you well
I'm going to show you how to glue them
together we're going to use this special
kind of pipeline this is not the normal
pipeline it's angle bracket equal angle
bracket special kind of pipeline for
these kinds of things um so I'm not
going to really show you how it works
but if you've ever played with a toy
train set um it looks like this after
you've combine them right so if you know
how to work with model wellways that's
how it works so that's how it works
inside it's actually pretty easy but I'm
not going to go into it right now let's
look at another web components let's
look at choose so what choose is is it
takes a list a list of web components
and each web component can you know
return I handle it or I didn't handle it
so what choose does is it goes through
each one in turn and it finds the first
one that handles the
input so if you know in this Cas maybe
it's the first one now if none of them
handle the input the whole the whole
choose thing doesn't handle it right so
choose
itself is one of these things where
there's an input and if it's successful
it will return an output and if none of
them work if none of them match it will
return nothing so it itself is another
web component so you can see I've built
a bigger web component from a bunch of
smaller web
components so um here's here's an
example of a very simple web app so I've
got the get combined with the root
combined with the okay which is our 200
right so if it matches get and it
matches the root then it's going to
return okay hello and if it matches get
and if it doesn't match the first one is
going to fail now if it matches get and
it matches the root and it the root is
goodbye then it's going to turn out
goodbye so if that one succeeds the
whole thing will succeed if none of
these succeed then the whole choose
itself is going to
fail right so there's a little very very
tiny web
app written using pipeline approach
right so it's a very different way of
writing a a web app that you might
normally
write so of course because this is a
pipeline you get all the benefits of
pipelines so I can add a new uh a new
pipeline a new thing to my choice right
I have a a post if it's a post and the
rout is bad it's a bad request and so on
and I can do things like checking
whether you're logged in uh if you are
logged in are you in the right role so
all these things I can just have these
single responsibility PR uh components
that I stick in my pipeline to build my
entire web app so each one of these
things is very small it does one thing
well and they can be tested
independently plus I think this is easy
to understand if you're if you're
looking at my code and you're saying
what does it do you can look at this
code and say oh yeah well you have to be
you have to be it's this you know it's
this path and uh you have to be
authorized and you have to be an admin
you know it's it's a lot easier to
understand this code I think than trying
to understand some complicated other
kind of
code so again just like with link all
the components are composable they're
reusable they're testable in isolation
they're single
responsibility all the stuff all the
good stuff I was talking about this is a
real a real world example of it so the
Lego model applied to website
development now let me actually prove
it's not just a a toy thing I'm actually
going to do a real app
here so this is my program
and by the way you can this is actually
using um it's it's sitting on top of net
there's my this is actually very old
version of this is like four years old
now so I'm using a a framework called
giraffe which is an F framework to do
this stuff but you can see it actually
it's got a startup function and so
on so once you get out of the net stuff
um you're into this nice F stuff so
here's my thing so get uh if it's hello
I'm going to return hello if it's uh a
post so I can differentiate between a
get and a post if you post a hello it's
going to turn post hello if you pass in
a parameter like a you know your name
it's going to say hello with name so
this is a little uh function I wrote
myself and all it does is it takes the
name parameter and it just spits out the
name
instead um goodbye all it does is it
says goodbye um there's a ping pong
Handler let's look at this one um so it
says another little choose this
component is a choose right so if you if
if the input is Ping it's going to
return pong and if the input's pong it's
going to return
ping right uh what the next one Jason so
here's a good example little Jason so
all I've done is a very little simple
data structure and I'm going to
serialize it to Jason and to it that's
this about as easy as get
right what else do we have oh yeah
here's a proper database so this is
something that loads A customer from the
database and I have this is my customer
database
and um if I let's look at this code this
is actually my database but you could
imagine real a real database behind the
scenes but basically I've got two
customers and if it's one or two I
return the customer and if it's anything
if it's not one or two I've got the
customer's not found right so obviously
I could replace this with a real async
code because all this could work totally
with async so that's my my my customer
database so what I'm going to do is load
the customer from the database and it
might exist or it might be an error
right so if it is is if it does exist
it's going to serialize the customer and
return it uh if the customer doesn't
exist I'm going to return a 400 and I'm
also going to take that error message
and return it in the response as well so
there's a you know very obviously it's a
very simple example but you can see that
you can get more complicated stuff going
here um how about access denied right so
if you go to the
denied let's see what that does so
denied I'm setting the status code to
401 and I'm going to turn this text as
well and finally the homepage is just
literally going to uh load up a static
site a static page and uh show on the
screen so let's actually run
this see if it
works
don't want one time thank
you right so I've got it my static page
just has a bunch of pre-built buttons so
I don't have to type all this stuff in
so I've got
hello right and that just returns
hello and there's the post so I've got a
post and a get and you can see that
returns different things if there's the
parameterized version of hello with
somebody's name and just to prove it
works I could put in somebody else's
name in here
and it still works
fine uh what else do we have here right
get goodbye so this is my message don't
say goodbye NDC never going to say
goodbye going to say hello to
NDC right there's
ping returns pong and there's pong which
returns
ping and there's my Jason example right
so I had a data structure in F and I
just serialized it to Jason and there it
is um uh what else do we have oh here's
my customers right so there's customer
number one partied By Number One
customer number
two uh and if I put in customer whoops
uh another customer which doesn't exist
customer 42 doesn't exist that's not
found and by the way never write your
apis where you're passing in custom IDs
that's it's just for demo purposes this
is like really bad security right okay
what else do we have oh yeah get
denied so actually let me open up the uh
Network and show you that it really was
denied there we go uh you can see over
here with look there you go I got a four
whoops I got a 401
there right so it really did return a
401 and it really did return an access
to n
message right okay so this is a working
website obviously it's pretty simple
pretty crude
but you know I did some database access
I did some Json calization I did some
security with access Den KN you know you
know you can actually write serious apps
now you might think f is that the best
thing well it's running on net it's just
as performant of C so if you can if
you're happy to write a backend in C
there's no reason why you can't write a
back end in F it's just as
performant so and oh and I I can also of
course I can put logging in there these
all these little pipelines you know I
can do all the stuff I can add to the
pipeline I can move things I can add
logging I can add you know authorization
and stuff because it's a
pipeline so this is f j so highly
encourage you to um check it out if you
want so all the code I've shown you is
actually on my GitHub um and if you go
to the fop for Fun and Profit pipeline
there's a link to my GitHub repo so you
can download it and play with the code
yourself right so let's finish up with
talking about testing and
architecture so I said at the beginning
I think that pipelines encourage good
architecture so what do I mean by that
well if you think about the modern
architectures you know onion and clean
and hexagonal and ports and adapters and
all those things the difference between
them and the old style database Centric
ones like an enter classic enter so in
classic enter the databases the bottom
is the core of the system in the modern
architectures the domain is the core of
the system and everything else is on the
outside the infrastructure and any apis
that you're interacting with the
database and so on all this is an
outside and your core domain is in the
middle that's the most important thing
right so how does this fit into the
pipeline well you write your pipeline
the same way you put you have a piece of
pipeline which is pure domain logic just
business rules and whatever decisions
and then anytime you interact with the
outside world you do that at the edges
of your pipeline so this is very easy um
to work with I actually think it's
easier than trying to do this o stuff
you know if you're using Entity
framework or something it's kind of
messy but if you're using this kind of
pipeline stuff it's really it's kind of
natural to put the io
outside so the core domain is pure it's
very it's deterministic is predictable
anything which is unpredictable um
anything to do with networks and
databases and you know all that stuff is
on the outside and the outside of your
app so I think it encourages good uh
good architecture so here's here's a
pipeline
with the business Logic the decision
making is in the middle right and it's
like I say it's really easy to enforce
this when I'm looking at the code into
if you're doing a code review because
you you're not mixing up different
things in the same each piece is single
responsibility so it's it's really
obvious whether it's doing wrong things
you know so you classic things is you
load some data from the database or you
receive some data on the network you
process it you know you analyze it you
come to a decisions like should I do
this should I do that and then based on
that you write some more data out of the
database or you turn some more data back
on the network or
whatever so that's a classic obviously
you know 99% of business applications
literally just follow this model
sometimes you have to make multiple
decisions that's fine but you in that
case I recommend you keep each step
separate so you have a decision-making
step and an IO step and another
decision-making step and another IO step
and keep them
separate now what about testing why is
this easier to test than conventional
code well again looking at this thing
this bit in the middle doesn't use any
IO doesn't so it's completely
deterministic right if you have a
particular input you'll always get the
same output right it's what you call
Pure
code right the stuff on the edges is not
deterministic you every time you load
the record from the DAT you might get a
different answer so um you know that's
very hard to test so but if you design
your code this way the testing falls out
really easily you do your unit tests on
the middle bit and you do your
integration tests on the entire
pipeline so it just just falls out and
by the way a unit test is not a
class-based thing a unit is a unit of
functionality right you're testing
that's what a unit is so don't think of
unit test as class based test it's a
unit of business logic is what you're
testing so here's I'm testing the middle
bit and it's very easy because it's like
there's no IO it's like completely
deterministic this input gives me that
output it's really fast to run really
easy to write and then you can save the
integration tests within the tire p
so to finish up why bother with all this
pipeline stuff well hopefully you know I
said at the beginning and hopefully I'm
going to go to to to persuaded you that
these things are actually useful I
talked about reusable components and you
can see especially like with a web app
that each of these little individual
things are completely reusable I can mix
and match build pipelines in complicated
ways um I said I think it's more
understandable and again if you look at
that web app I think I actually think
there is a lot more understandable than
the classic we about because all the
code is like in one all the kind of
overview is in one place and all the
individual components do their stuff
just like with the link the link code
was more understandable than a
complicated for Loop right so I I
definitely think pipelines are easy to
understand we talked about extendability
you can see it's really easy to add new
components I can add new components I
can add new features to my pipeline um
really easily and I'm not touching any
old code so I have very high confidence
when I do add a new piece to my pipeline
I'm not going to break anything and that
to me that's worth a
lot um much more testable each of these
individual pieces are one single
responsibility they can do one thing
they're much easier to test in isolation
and then when I do combine them I have
again I have high confidence that
they're going to work as a whole that
there's not going to be some weird side
effects and interaction between them
that I wasn't expecting and finally it's
just a different way of thinking I do
think that it's different it's good for
your brain to learn different ways of
thinking and if you've only ever done o
I highly recommend you learn other ways
of thinking I suggest pipeline oriented
functional programming logic programming
like prologue stack based programming
like fourth is it's really good for your
brain to learn these different ways
because if you learn these different
things you will come up with different
solutions like pipeline thinking gave me
three different solutions for things you
probably would do normally in a very
different way you'd probably never write
the rumal thing that way you probably
never write F buuz that way and you
probably never write a web app that way
but I think there you know if if you're
thinking pipelines you'll start thinking
that way about solving your problems so
is it going to work in every situation
no I'm not claiming this is a universal
tool that will help you for everything
but I think it's part of your toolkit
right every developer should know about
databases they should know about o
programming they should definitely know
about domain Des different design and I
think they should know about pipeline
programs so it's just a part of your
toolkit that you can reach for when you
have a particular
problem so that's the talk um as I said
I'm going to put the slides and the
video up on my website so this is f
forun and profit Pipeline and also my
code is there if you want to run the
code for yourself if you like this talk
I have other talks I have one on
composition and I have one on wellway Ed
programming which is where I talk about
how you can combine these uh multiple
track Railways into a single system it's
all about error handling functional
error handling so I like that one and
then of course I have a book uh domain
model made functional and you can find
me on Twitter at Lan and I'm also on
Foster done with the same handle and uh
yeah if you have any questions please
contact me there so thanks very much and
I'll be here for questions um I'll stick
around for a bit if you have if you want
to come up and ask me questions so
thanks very
[Applause]
much